[Music]
foreign
you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with Daily Mirror
columnist Susie Boniface and the acting
Deputy political editor of the mail on
Sunday Claire Ellicott so let's see
what's on some of those front pages for
you now the eye claims an exclusive with
a report that Russia's top mercenary
organization the Wagner group is
fighting in the conflict in Sudan
the times says there are serious
concerns about how the latest strike by
nurses beginning tomorrow will affect
Great Ormond Street Children's Hospital
in London
and amid what it calls the growing chaos
in the NHS the telegraph carries a
warning from the head of the Royal
College of Surgeons of England that his
members are only carrying out scheduled
operations one day a week
the guardian leads with the resignation
of BBC chairman Richard Sharp over his
connections with Boris Johnson and says
Rishi sunak is now Under Pressure to
stop appointing conservatives to senior
positions in the corporation
the financial times also goes with that
story the headline there sharp quits BBC
over Johnson loan
another exclusive this time for the sun
which says top secret documents about
Britain's nuclear submarine Fleet were
left in a pub toilet in Cumbria
Susie's paper the mirror looks ahead to
next week's coronation with a poll which
it says most people support the king's
plan to slim down the monarchy
the mail reports that Marx and Spencer
and Victoria Beckham have joined its
campaign to stop tourists to the UK
having to pay tax on purchases for
export a move which the paper says would
help boost the economy
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Susie Boniface and Claire Ellicott
welcome to you both let's start with the
I front page and Sudan at the war raging
there but uh Revelation tonight
um exclusive that the eye is claiming
Susie take us into this story
yep so this is about uh what's known as
the wardner group that's a an
organization which is supposed to be
independent of the Russian government uh
it is run by someone known as Putin's
Chef because he once put on some nice
dinners for Vladimir Putin supposed to
be completely independent but in fact
the Wagner group is known to be
operating as sort of a I don't know the
words not extrajudicial but as an arm of
the Russian State uh and in which there
is a degree of plausible deniability
should we say and it's been seen
operating in Conflict zones around the
world it's been operating in Ukraine for
example on behalf of of Russian
interests and here uh the eye has found
out that it has been operating in Sudan
as the Civil War grows up now Russia's
got a loss of Investments as has China
um really in Africa with raw materials
and so on and here it seems that the
Wagner group mercenaries some of whom
get recruited from prisons and things
um have been there protecting vast goal
shipments that they're trying to shift
back to Moscow and of course that's one
of the ways in which they're funding the
fight in Ukraine so they found these
Wagner mercenaries in Sudan they've
managed to establish that the mod is
actually monitoring them and knows that
they're there and seen fighting near the
capital of karting and it sort of raises
questions really about the role that
this unusual and
um highly unorthodox group is playing in
World conflicts it's been seen in
Ukraine it's been seen in Sudan where
else are they operating how many of them
are there who's in control of it I'm
sure that's one of the things that our
security services are spending half
their days trying to figure out
yes Claire I mean it's what does this
mean basically that is the question
yeah well it's I mean it's a shocking
Revelation and I've actually you know in
a number of the conflicts we've seen
around the world not least Ukraine and
the Wagner group's name continuously
keeps coming up and there have been
calls to prescribe the group
um to stop to make sure that you know
any kind of organizations affiliated
with them are going to be sanctioned and
some of those sanctions have been
carried out in the UK but there are huge
concerns about this group which operates
and you know is Putin they're based in
Russia you know they're tied to Putin
um but they seem to operate all over the
world
um one of the key things they seem to be
doing in Sudan at the moment is trying
to safeguard some shipments of gold and
this gold there are suggestions that
Russia will be using that to fund the
war with Ukraine and so there are huge
questions for the rest of the world as
well about what they do about this
because if this group of mercenaries are
backed by Putin are able to sort of
operate in all of these conflict zones
around the world in order to continue to
fight in Ukraine and the you know the
West has huge huge problems on their
hands and something sort of needs to be
done about it but at the moment Sudan is
uncomfortable you know the fighting
continues to rage and britons are being
airlifted out there at the moment and
we've had that you know about 1 500 100
Brits have been evacuated it's not quite
clear how many are there they think they
might be four thousand Nationals but um
you know this is continuing but it will
end tomorrow night and Susie as you say
the UK Ministry of defense is tracking
the activity of the the Wagner group but
uh what if any action could possibly be
be taken
well it's not just whether or not you
want to take action against sort of a an
extra supranational group like this
which is unable to sort of acting with
impunity around the world in conflicts
where the Russian state for example
wouldn't want to be seen acting it's
also when you've got situations like
this where sedans kind of on fire you've
got lots of Nations sending their own
troops to evacuate including some of our
own
um and here we've got the Wagner group
operating in the same area now what
happens if you get in a situation where
British troops are there and they're
trying to evacuate people we're sending
a couple of Warships to Port Sudan to
try and get some of those people out
what happens if they come under attack
what happens if they come under Fire
what happens if some Wagner group
mercenaries get the wrong end of the
stick you know things can can blow up
very very Suddenly by mistake as well as
by intent and if something's going
horribly wrong in Ukraine is it in
Vladimir Putin's best interest perhaps
to start causing a distraction in Port
Sudan by attacking a British warship for
example in you know in um in retaliation
for us sending weapons to zielinski and
his his freedom fighters so it can go
horribly horribly wrong and you could
end up with a group like this having a
conflict between Russia and the West in
a place that you weren't expecting it in
a way that no one can control
um and that's why our security services
are monitoring it so closely and then it
gets to the point of not do you want to
do something about it but is it wise to
do anything about it yes do you actually
just want to give each other a very wide
berth in order to avoid a conflict
suddenly escalating but but they're not
because they're going to be in in the
same space Claire so it's a a big
conundrum really isn't it for the
British government and the the defense
services
yes of course and it's very unclear what
they can do I mean Sudan is has not
really got a government at the moment
and there's so much fighting there that
there's there's not a lot Britain can do
and we've we've already you know there's
a ceasefire that's been um agreed to 72
hours ceasefire
um which would enable all of other
countries that have foreign Nationals
there to evacuate their citizens and
that comes to an end tomorrow night so
there is a rush to get the last
remaining people who are there out of
out of the area and to send these
warships in to rescue anyone who's left
behind but there's no doubt that a lot
of the people in Sudan who aren't in
cartoon and near the airfields they have
just already fled over borders and
Britain doesn't monitor where its
citizens go like this so it's not quite
clear where they all are
um but it is a huge conundrum and you
know Britain will have to do what it can
working in concert with other nations to
ensure that this doesn't escalate and
that there isn't some sort of proxy wall
with the Wagner group or otherwise in
any way yeah very delicate situation
there at the moment let us move to the
times and uh strikes a word that has
been littered across our media for for
several months now and this Nationwide
strike by NHS nurses the um Great Ormond
Street is saying that it's literally
going to put the lives of Children at
Risk and their calling to to be made
exempt from the action being taken Susie
yeah and this just sort of shows really
the problems of the the strikes the
industrial action that we've seen in
Industry after industry is not going
away anytime soon it's it's going to get
worse over the next probably a couple of
years although some nurses and some
sorry some NHS workers have voted to
accept the payoff at the Royal College
of nurses is still going out on strike
now the way that you get the nurses who
are striking to agree
um you know some basic safety levels for
things like Great Ormond Street and
Cancer Care and intensive care which
everybody would want is if you negotiate
with them in good faith and they know
that you're going to come to the table
and we can talk about everything else
just make sure you don't do this sort of
thing and that's not what's happening
with the way the government's handled it
added to which although
um it's horrific to think about you know
anyone not being at work in a hospital
when they could be
fact is that there are 46 000 nursing
vacancies at the moment and that must be
affecting places like the Great Ormond
Street Hospital intensive care units and
cancer Wards every single day in this
country what's happening with the strike
is that the absences are kind of being
concentrated into a couple of days or
one day and it's becoming more
noticeable and it causes cancellations
and other issues for people
um but you know if you want to fix it
you have to fix the the problem with the
nursing vacancies and unfortunately I
think it was in 2018 Theresa May in her
wisdom decided to ask the nursing
bursary which provided funding for
nurses to study a degree that has since
come back in again but that kicking
through the system has just stopped the
number of nurses coming in then you
throw on top of that the pandemic and
that's increased the number of nurses
who are leaving two-thirds of the nurses
that leave now are under the age of 45
right they're not retiring they're burnt
out they're Fed Up and they're ill
that's why they're leaving and that's
partly because there haven't been enough
nurses in the system you've got to fix
some of the fundamental structural
issues with providing staff in the NHS
and then you don't have these strikes
that's obviously a long-term thing and
they've got to fix this in the short
term to make sure there's enough Care on
on call for services that need it yeah
it's the short term that's worrying that
the chief executive of a Great Ormond
Street Claire and he's saying that we
respect the right of our staff to take
part in lawful industrial action but
after exhausting all options we have
serious concerns over how we will safely
staff our Hospital during the strike
these children have no voice in the
debate and we must protect them he's
almost pleading
I mean it's a deeply worrying words from
him and we've got a situation where and
the nurse is going to go out and strike
and there's no exemption for critical
care services for cancer patients for
these sick children in Great Ormond
Street I think the trouble is that what
striking workers are reliant on the
Goodwill of the public and the public
accepting that you know they have a good
case because if they don't then the
government has no real incentive to
negotiate with them and and the problem
I think with this is that people are
going to read the newspapers tomorrow
they're going to read these stories and
think you know Great Ormond Street you
know synonymous with caring for children
and looking after people their workers
are going on strike and children there
could be at risk it's hard to hear that
it's really really difficult and I think
the trouble is that the RCN are reliant
on the Public's favor and um you know
they've rejected the government's offer
they're starting to look isolated
because a lot of the other healthcare
worker unions have said that they will
set the offer and the offer may end up
still going through despite the RCN and
the RCM are going on strike again I
think it becomes slightly problematic
when the public see these damaging
headlines and These Warnings from you
know Britain's best known hospital that
children could possibly be in danger I
think it's hard it's going to be hard
for them to keep the public on side if
things like this continue because with
no exemptions these children are clearly
at risk let's move to the guardian just
got time for that before the break Susie
uh and this story following on from the
resignation of Richard Sharp that the
guardian is looking at uh Rishi sunak's
future role in appointing um a chairman
and where he should be looking
exactly and it's to do with the entire
public appointment system really so
Richard Sharp got the job having told
the Prime Minister who was already he's
told this inquiry he considered him to
be his boss as it was so then he goes in
and tells his boss he wants to get
another job which isn't really for the
boss but I'm and I'm now going to be you
have to be entirely independent of you
when I'm doing this job and impartial
and actually scrutinizing you but I need
your permission to go and do it and you
need to appoint me Boris Johnson then
created a a committee to to pick the BBC
chairman and he plunked several people
on that committee over the heads of the
Department of culture who are drawing up
a short list he then told that committee
several times that he wanted Richard
Sharp to get the job now that's not
independent and it's not the way to pick
an independent person to lead an
independent organization which is what
everyone needs the BBC to do it's the
equivalent of me going to my editor and
saying hello boss I would like to suck
up to you in a slightly different way
tomorrow is that all right and we'll
pretend and that we don't know anything
about it we've never met before and my
boss will go yeah all right why not that
sounds good you know that's not how you
pick the chairman of the BBC but even
after this even after Richard Sharp
resigning that is going to be a very
similar process which is open to Rishi
suneg to use and abuse if he wants to
the same way Boris Johnson did we have
to have some rules about public life in
this country and where our standards are
because Richard Sharp signed the Nolan
principles on public life and completely
ignored them he's now had to resign
about two years after everybody else
figured out there was something wrong
with it
there's independent committees setting
this stuff up because you can't rely on
politicians to do it in a way that's
decent and reasonable for everybody
they'll only do it in a way that's
decent for them